what would you like your
tombstone to read it's a good way to
summarize
the uh essence of a human being i would
like it to say this has not been paid
for
and i want i want my my living relatives
to
struggle to to pay for it and i think i
would like them to be hounded every day
i would like people to call and go
listen we don't want to ever excavate a
body but we will
because this has not been paid for
i i love the idea of leaving the world
like debt
leaving the world in in lots of debt
that other people have to deal with
yeah and i i know people that have done
that and i know people that have been in
families where that's happened where
someone has to sit and and just curse
the sky
because they don't have a physical
person anymore to be angry at
and they but they still have to deal
with the decisions that person made
and that's deeply tragic but that's
always struck me is very funny well it's
the kind of
immortality the debt because you can if
the debt lasts for a long time
the anger lasts for a long time and then
you're now immortal
in the minds of many you arouse emotion
in the minds of many
my mother's best friend in the town i
grew up and her husband
shot himself in the the
driveway and my mother's friend never
got a chance to just grieve
because he owed so much money she would
come over and go i
hate him i [ __ ] hate him
and it was just such an interesting
thing to see somebody who and her kids
ended up getting angry at her for that
because they didn't understand why she
would hate a guy who was clearly you
know
suffering and but she goes he took the
selfish way out
he [ __ ] us and it was always
interesting for me to
uh just remember that like you can leave
earth
and still be a problem
[Laughter]
that's kind of a special person so
that's i think what i'd like my
tombstone to read
you